DEMOCRATS CLEARLY WORRIED
REPUBLICANS WILL PASS THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS MEASURE AND
SAVIOR DONE.
STAY ON MIKE EMANUEL, THANKS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT GUNS, SCHOOL
SAFETY AND OTHERS SUBJECTS WITH
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
LET'S START WITH THE STORY WE
LEAD WITH, THE SECURITY
CLEARANCE ISSUE FOR JARED
KUSHNER.
DOWNGRADED TO SECRET.
HOW IS THAT SITTING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND HOW DOES IT
AFFECT HIS JOB?
>> I HAVE NOT DISCUSSED IT
DIRECTLY WITH JERROD OR ANYONE
ELSE.
JERROD IS IN CHARGE OF OR
SUPPORTS MANY OF THE DIFFERENT
INITIATIVES BY THE PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON FRIDAY IN
FRONT OF THE WHOLE WORLD, THE
PRESS CONFERENCE WITH THE
AUSTRALIAN PRIME MINISTER.
HE HAS GREAT FAITH IN JARED
KUSHNER SENIOR ADVISOR.
WORKING ON MIDDLE EAST PEACE.
HE'S BEEN INVOLVED WITH NAFTA.
HE SAID A GREAT DEAL TO DO WITH
CHINA.
HE'S BEEN INVOLVED, I DON'T KNOW
THE STATUS OF OTHER PEOPLE'S
SECURITY CLEARANCES, NOR DO I
WANT TO.
I FIND OF THE ENTIRE PROCESS ONE
THAT SHOULD BE TIGHTLY HELD AND
NOT WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF
COLLEAGUES AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
I EXPECT THE REST OF US WILL BE
INFORMED AS WE NEED TO BE.
>> Bret: INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS SAY 50% TO 75% OF THE
MATERIAL THAT GOES OVER THE NSC
NSC'S DESK IS TOP-SECRET.
DEALING WITH MIDDLE EAST PEACE.
THAT'S A LOT OF TOP SECRET
STUFF.
I LEAVE THAT TO JARED AND THE
NSC AND OTHERS.
I REMIND YOU --
>> Bret: DO YOU EXPECT THE
CLEARANCES ARE COMING THROUGH?
>> I HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
THAT AND IT'S NOT FOR ME TO
COMMENT.
>> Bret: "WASHINGTON POST"
SAYING OFFICIALS AND AT LEAST
FOUR COUNTRIES HAVE PRIVATELY
DISCUSSED WAYS THEY CAN
MANIPULATE JARED KUSHNER BY
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF HIS COMPLEX
BUSINESS ARRANGEMENTS, FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES AND LACK OF FOREIGN
POLICY EXPERIENCE.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO A STORY
LIKE THAT?
>> I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
READ IT.
I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
DISCUSS IT WITH JARED AND
OTHERS.
I CAN'T REALLY COMMENT ON A
STORY THAT IS NEWLY POSTED.
WHAT I WILL SAY IS I THINK
THERE'S PEOPLE OUT THERE GUNNING
FOR FOLKS ALL OF THE TIME.
THAT GOES BEYOND DOING ONE'S JOB
AS A REPORTER, AS A JOURNALIST.
SINCE THE MOMENT WE ARRIVED
HERE, THEY HAVE BEEN THROWING
LOGS IN OUR PATH.
IT DOESN'T DETER THE PRESIDENT
FROM CARRYING OUT THE AGENDA.
HE'S HAD TREMENDOUS PROGRESS AND
DELIVERED RESULTS AGAIN AND
AGAIN DESPITE, REALLY DESPITE
UNPRECEDENTED NEGATIVITY THROWN
ON HIS WAY AND IN THE WAY OF HIS
FAMILY AND ADVISORS.
>> Bret: IN WHITE HOUSE PALACE
INTRIGUE, IS THERE A BATTLE
BETWEEN JOHN KELLY AND DIFFERENT
MEMBERS, INCLUDING JARED
KUSHNER?
>> I HAVE NOT SEEN THAT.
THE GENERAL, I CAN IMAGINE.
HE HAS A GREAT DEAL OF RESPECT
AND SUPPORT AMONG THE STAFF IN
THE BUILDING.
NOT ONLY BECAUSE HE HAS BROUGHT
STRUCTURE AND DISCIPLINE AND
ORDER AND A PROCESS AND I THINK
IT BENEFITS THE PRESIDENT.
THE MAN IS THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AND LEADER OF
THE FREE WORLD.
HE OUGHT TO HAVE TIME TO GET
INPUT AND IDEAS.
GENERAL KELLY IS ORIENTED
DIFFERENTLY FOR MANY OF US.
HE CAME FROM THE CABINET.
HE IS A GREAT DEAL OF RESPECT ON
CAPITOL HILL AND AMONG CABINET
MEMBERS.
HERE AMONG THE SENIOR STAFF.
>> Bret: LET'S TALK SUBSTANCE
ON THE GUN ISSUE.
HERE SENATOR JOHN CORNYN TODAY.
>> IF OUR ATTITUDE IS I WANT
EVERYTHING IN MY LIST OR
NOTHING, WE ARE GOING TO END UP
WITH NOTHING.
LET'S DO WHAT WE CAN IMMEDIATELY
TO PASS AND BUILD FROM THERE.
THINGS LIKE BUMP STOCKS, MENTAL
HEALTH FAILURES.
>> Bret: WHAT IS REALISTIC?
FOR IMMIGRATION, YOU HAVE
PILLARS YOU HAD TO HAVE.
ARE THERE PILLARS WHEN IT COMES
TO GUN CONTROL AND SAFETY,
SCHOOL SAFETY?
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS SPOKEN
EXTENSIVELY.
HE'S BEEN TALKING TO AFFECTED
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS.
OBVIOUSLY PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS.
YESTERDAY TO THE GOVERNORS.
I SAT IN ON ALL THREE SESSIONS
AND I CAN TELL YOU, EVEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH MEMBERS ON
CAPITOL HILL, THE PRESIDENT
SUPPORTS INCREASING THE AGE
PERHAPS FOR POSSESSION OF SOME
FIREARMS.
HE CERTAINLY SUPPORTS FIXING
NICS, THE BACKGROUND CHECKS.
HE HAS TALKED ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH, HE'S TALKED ABOUT HOW HE
WANTS TO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR PEOPLE WHO SHOULDN'T HAVE
FIREARMS TO HAVE THEM BUT EASIER
FOR THOSE WHO SHOULD AND SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO CARRY THEM UNDER
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
WHEN I SAY EASIER, FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO DO ITS JOB ALSO
AND GIVE RESOURCES, TOOLS FOR
THE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN IN
CHARGE OF THIS.
IT'S A COMPLEX ISSUE.
I THINK NERVES HAVE BEEN RAW
BECAUSE WE ARE SO MOVED AND
SADDENED AND ANGERED BY WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN PARKLAND AND
ELSEWHERE.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT, LIKE HE DID
ON IMMIGRATION, ON ENERGY
POLICY, TAXES, HE IS BRINGING
BOTH PARTIES IN BOTH CHAMBERS
INTO THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE IS GOING TO THEM AND WORKING.
HE IS TALKING TO THEM ABOUT
WHAT'S POSSIBLE.
IN THE END, CONGRESS WILL NEED
TO ACT AND THE PRESIDENT WILL
SIGN INTO LAW SOMETHING THAT IS
REASONABLE COMMON SENSE THAT
GETS US CLOSER TO KEEPING SCHOOL
CHILDREN SAFE I CAN IMAGINE
THAT'S NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
WE HAVE HEARD REALLY GOOD OTHER
IDEAS, INCLUDING FROM THE
GOVERNORS YESTERDAY.
A SINGLE POINT OF ENTRY FOR SOME
SCHOOLS.
OTHERS ARE ARGUING FOR ARMED
GUARDS.
OTHERS ARE ARGUING, AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
>> Bret: THE PILLARS AREN'T
SET.
IDEAS ON THE TABLE.
HE SAID NUMEROUS TIMES THE NRA
IS GOING TO COME AROUND, THAT
THEY ARE WITH US.
DON'T WORRY.
DON'T BE SCARED OF THEM.
IS THE NRA GOING TO COME AROUND?
SO FAR THEY ARE NOT, RAISING THE
>> THE NRA HAS SPOKEN CLEARLY
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AS TO WHAT
THEY SUPPORT AND DON'T.
THEY HAVE BEEN FOR STRONGER
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR
INDIVIDUALS.
THEY TALKED ABOUT MAKING SURE.
PENALTIES FOR COMMITTING A CRIME
WITH A FIREARM ILLEGALLY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BROUGHT THEM
TO THE TABLE.
HE SAID YESTERDAY HE MET WITH
THE DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE HAD LUNCH WITH MEMBERS OF THE
NRA, TOP BRASS.
WHEN HE SAYS THEY WILL COME
AROUND, I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
SAYING EVERYBODY HAS AN INTEREST
IN MAKING SURE SCHOOLCHILDREN
ARE SAFE AND NO PARENT SHOULD
KISS THEIR CHILD COULD BUY, YOU
AND ME INCLUDED, NOT SEE THEM
AGAIN.
WE AS A NATION NEED TO ACT AND
NOT OVERREACT.
>> Bret: MARCH 5 RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER, THE DACA DEADLINE.
THE COURTS HAVE DONE WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE OR NOT DONE COME IN
THE CASE OF THE SUPREME COURT.
WHAT IS THE SENSE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ABOUT WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO DO?
>> DACA IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
THE PRESIDENT BEING OPENED UP A
PEOPLE'S IDEAS AND SAYING OKAY,
THAT I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE CARE
OF THE 600,000.
WE WILL DO ALL 1.8 MILLION.
HE SAID THAT IN A BICAMERAL,
BIPARTISAN MEETING IN THE
CABINET ROOM.
FOX NEWS COVERED THE ENTIRE HOUR
FOX NEWS COVERED THE ENTIRE HOU
HOUR.
YET YOU CAN'T HAVE THE DEMOCRATS
BACK TO THE TABLE.
THEY WON'T COME BACK AND FIX IT.
THIS CONGRESS HAD ALL OF LAST
YEAR TO DO IT.
THE PRESIDENT GAVE THEM ANOTHER
SIX MONTHS TO DO IT AND THEY
HAVEN'T ACTED.
YOU HAVE TO ASK WHY?
DO THEY CARE ABOUT HAVING A
BLUNT INSTRUMENT AGAINST THE
PRESENT AND THE PARTY OR DO THEY
CARE ABOUT HELPING THE DREAMERS?
>> Bret: IS THERE AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER COMING, SOMETHING ELSE
FROM THIS WHITE HOUSE?
>> IF IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
ON CAPITOL HILL, I KNOW THE
PRESIDENT IS EXAMINING OTHER
AVENUES AND OPTIONS.
REMEMBER, ONE BODY IN THIS TOWN
MAKES THE LAWS.
ONE EXECUTES IT.
THE OTHER INTERPRETS IT.
WE HAVE THREE SEPARATE BUT EQUAL
BRANCHES.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN ACTION
THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER WHEN HE
THINKS OTHERS ARE SLOW TO ACT OR
WHEN HE IS IN A POSITION TO DO
IT.
WE'VE SEEN THEM DO IT WITH
HEALTH CARE, FOR EXAMPLE, TRYING
TO OPEN UP HEALTH CARE BENEFITS
TO OTHERS WHEN REPEALING AND
REPLACING OBAMACARE FAILED ON
CAPITOL HILL.
TO GET COAL MINER BENEFITS BACK.
REGULATORY REFORMS.
TAKE US OUT OF TPP, TAKE US OUT
OF WHAT HE CONSIDERS TO BE A BAD
DEAL.
HE WILL ACTIVE HIS AUTHORITY